[Musique]
je je me sens une merde pas au
travail j'arrive pas les Français n'ont
jamais été aussi malheureux au travail
44 % d'entre eux s'estiment en état de
détresse psychologique plus de 2 tiers
seraiit stressé par leur emploi on est
en train de devenir dingue trop d'email
trop de trop de réunion conséquence de
dizaines d'années où il a fallu gagner
en productivité on est dans le toujours
plus avec toujours moins de salariés et
toujours moins de moyens les gens qui
souffrent de leur travail ils sont perdu
parce qu'il doivent faire face à des
objectifs
inatteignables instauration du
télétravail dislocation des équipes la
crise sanitaire a accentué le mal-être
tout ce qui donne sens par rapport au
travail a changé il y a vraiment eu un
avant et un après covid alors que disent
les gens qui souffrent au travail
comment prévenir les principaux risques
som nous arri au bout d'un système moi
j'attends le
boul je suis convaincu que ça finira
[Musique]
venir quand on parle de souffrance au
travail il faut d'abord citer un fait la
France détient le sombre record du plus
grand nombre d'accidents du travail en
Europe plus de 630000 par an deux fois
plus que la moyenne des pays européens
dans son cabinet de médecine du travail
allez-y Muriel du mortier reçoit ses
salariés
blessész ce matinl il s'agit d'une
responsable d'un magasin de meuble qui
après un arrêt de travail de plusieurs
mois fait une visite de
préreprise alors l'accident du travail
c'était quand le 11 AOT
2020 2020 qu'est-ce qui vous est arrivé
je suis tombé dans les
escaliers réserve d'accord du coup
vous êtes tombé vous vous êtes pas
arrêté j'imagine j'ai oui je me suis
accroché à mon travail voilà est-ce que
parce que il y avait besoin voilà et
j'ai eu du mal à à quitter le navire et
et à me prendre en charge et en fait
c'est la douleur qui n'était plus
possible plus tenable je ne dormais plus
je souffrais et mon bras ne fonctionnait
absolument plus donc il fallait vraiment
faire quelque chose mais ça toutes les
études montrent que les travailleurs
français sont des bons professionnels
qui aiment leur métier qui aiment leur
entreprise et vous en êtes encore une
illustration là voilà j'en suis la PRU
voilà la preuve c'est que même quand on
a mal on y va quand même c'est ça c'est
ça en France plus d'un tiers des
salariés travaillent alors qu'ils sont
malades et Muriel du mortier a bien du
mal à faire entendre raison à sa
patiente là j'ai repris jeudi pour
l'instant j'ai pas j'ai pas repris la
alors moi je pense que prendre à temps
plein ce que vous avez fait c'est pas
forcément une bonne idée et moi je vous
encourage vraiment à reprendre en M temp
thérapeutique en temps partiel c'est
compliqué dans votre fonction ça va pas
être gérable parce que on trouve pas de
personnel je encore une fois je ne suis
pas irremplaçable mais j'ai précisé que
je reprenais à temps complet j'ai repris
à temps complet je me vois pas dire
maintenant
finalement non je reprends canitan donc
je marque peux reprendre le
travail sur un poste aménager à
condition de ne pas faire de manutention
manuelle supérieure à 5 kg ne doit pas
travailler bras en
l'air d'orog douleurs aux épaules
douleur au dos ou au
poignet des pathologies regroupées sous
le nom de troubles musculossquelettiqu
des
TMS la maladie professionnelle la plus
répandue chez les salariés
français cette dame vient pour une
simple visite de routine mais très vite
la docteur du mortier va constater
qu'elle est usée par le
[Musique]
travail vous travaillez là vous faites
le ménage à l'hôpital oui depuis combien
de temps vous faites ce ménage depuis
maintenant 6 ans là-bas c'est pas facile
c'est tout
il y a beaucoup du boulot ouis ou ouais
au niveau de votre santé là il y a eu
des choses nouvelles depuis la dernière
visite maintenant là j'ai j'ai mal au
épau ah vous avez mal à
l'épaule l'épaule gauche et dans le dos
vous avez mal aussi oui des fois j'ai
mal au
dos por de charge trop lourde geste
répétitif contrairement aux idées reçues
les TMS tou
voires allez tomez bien les bras vous
les mettez bien bien comme ça vous allez
résister à ce que je vais vous faire
d'accord vous faites les bras bien dur
vous résistez non faites les bras durs
vous résistez vous résistez résistez je
vous fais mal
là là de ce côté-là c'est allez encore
le bras dur là je vais les monter les
bras pour résistez vous
savez va falloir que vous mettiez sur
votre bras au repos
madame vous avez une inflammation là au
niveau des tondons et au niveau des
muscles de l'épaule si vous tardez trop
si vous tirez trop sur cette épaule
douloureuse vous allez l'abîmer encore
beaucoup plus et après ça sera encore
beaucoup plus compliqué pour vous je
sais bien que pour vous vous vous
attendiez pas du tout à ça là
aujourd'hui hein que pour vous c'est un
petit choc bon vous avez 58 ans faut
faire attention à vous
madame dans son cabinet la médecin voit
de plus en plus de salariés souffrant de
TMS dès 50 ans et s'interroge au moment
où le report du départ à la retraite
rallonge encore les carrières dans la
grande majorité des emplois on est dans
le toujours plus avec toujours moins de
salariés et toujours moins de moyens
voilà et donc du coup bien a une usure
prématurée articuliire il est largement
temps de penser condition de travail si
on veut maintenir les gens on travaille
beaucoup plus longtemps bon pourquoi pas
ça peut-être que ça se justifie au
niveau politique j'ai pas j'ai pas
d'avis à donner là sur la question mais
mais en tout cas si on veut faire ça
faut réellement faire de la prévention
dans les entreprises alors certaines
entreprises prennent le sujet à bras le
corp nous sommes chez l'un des leaders
du secteur du nettoyage des métiers où
les cas de TMS sont deux fois plus
importants que chez le reste des
salariés ce jour-là des médecins du
travail viennent constater les mesures
mises en place depuis 2 ans pour
prévenir les
[Musique]
TMS je vousite r dans dans les
sanitaires pour voir la première
démonstration c'est parti je vous en
prie allez-y pardon
merci donc Sandra tu vas nous
expliquer ça c'était avant donc là comme
vous pouvez constater sur l'intervention
de Sandra l'épaule il est beaucoup
sollicité pas de droite à gauche donc
c'est un effort physique qui est quand
même qui est quand même considérable
même les chevill sont sollicités dans ce
genre d'intervention ouis en temps
normal Sandra nettoie une dizaine de
sanitaires par vacation donc le fait de
travailler matin et soir donc on ramène
ça à la journée ça fait une vingtaine de
sanitaires c'est dire une vingtaine de
miroir nettoyer forcément il y a de
l'impact sur les articulations d'où la
la la nécessité de trouver des solutions
pour lutter contre les
TMS mais avec l'introduction d'outils
bien pensés les gestes sont
[Musique]
différents
le salarié il est quand même ENF il fait
moins d'effort physique comparé à
comparé à avant là c'est les deux
épaules en fait qui travaillent alors
que j'ai remarqué avant c'est une seule
épaule RTI différemment et surtout les
appuis au niveau de
sol et l'idéal aussi c'est d'alterner
les tâches c'està-dire que quand il y a
quelqu'un qui fait essentiellement ce
type d'activité c'est vrai que ça peut
engendrer là aussi plus facilement des
TMS du coup ça vous amène aussi à
réfléchir à comment vous concevez fiche
de poste et ques sont les tages qui sont
demandé
exactement l'arrivée de nouveaux
accessoires permet aussi d'éviter les
chutes on va tourner comme ça de cette
façonl chercher l'armoire selon la
hauteur c'est parti
Sandra dans une entreprise où la moyenne
d'âge est de près de 50 ans et on peine
à recruter les TMS sont un
fléoent beaucoup d'absence d'arrêt de
travail
et on fait des déclarations de maladie
professionnelle donc ce qui a un coût
évidemment pour pour l'entreprise
également depuis la mise en place de ces
simples outils l'entreprise a vu ses
arrêts de travail baissé et son turnover
réduit quand vous avez beaucoup de
personnes qui s'absentent donc forcément
il faut les remplacer remplacer
quelqu'un qui est qui est titulaire d'un
qui est formé c'est toujours compliqué
parce que la prestation ne sera jamais
faite à 100 % de la même façon qu'un
titulaire on a un agent qui travaille
dans de bonnes conditions et on a
surtout moins de moins de coûts comparé
à comparé à des à des arrêts maladie à
répétition ça veut dire que c'est un bon
investissement en fait c'est très bon
investissement très bon investissement
aujourd'hui on est très content d'avoir
lancé ce programme et on compte pas
s'arrêter là mais depuis la crise
sanitaire ces TMS ne sont plus la
première cause d'arrêt de de travail de
longue durée ils ont été devancés par
des troubles psychologiques dus au
travail l'Institut de veille sanitaire
chiffre à 30000 le nombre de Burnout
chaque année mais le ressenti est tout
autre selon le dernier baromètre Opinion
Way sur la santé psychologique des
salariés 30 % se disent au bord du
burnout plus de 2 tiers des salariés dis
subir un stress
régulier installez-vous je vous en prie
ce matin c'est une manager dans un
cabinet de consulting qui a demandé à
être reçu par la médecin du travail
elle n'en peut
plus j'ai pas mal de responsabilités il
faut que je réalise les mission chez les
clients puis à côté il faut que je
m'occupe de recrutement de l'avant donc
viofre soutenance et cetera j'ai de la
gestion de carrière aussi à faire sur
une partie des
consultants plusieurs fois par semaine
je me sous h mais mais sur trois fois
rien on va me demander tiens contacte bu
pour faire telle chose ça prend 10
minutes mais je je pendant 2 heures
minimum je je me mets à pleurer et je
suis incapable de faire quoi que ce soit
j'arrive pas est-ce que vous en avez
parlé là à votre
on m'a dit tu as choisi de faire du
Conseil tu as choisi de travailler plus
pour gagner plus donc il est normal bah
de faire des nocturnes de faire des
weekends voilà depuis je arrêter de
parler parce que j'ai enfin ça ça rend
plus un
dialogue bon vous avez vu la DRH madame
d'accord bah ça va être la personne à
voir là parce que je vous rappelle que
dans le code du travail celui qui est
responsable des conditions de travail de
l'état de la santé mentale et et
physique des salariés c'est l'employeur
et donc son représentant hein c'est la
DRH qui doit être au courant faut pas
que ça vous change il faut pas que ça
vous change votre manière de voir le
travail il faut pas que ça change tout
ça vous voyez ce que je veux dire
ou oui oui oui je le
vois il y a quand
même je trouve tout
s'accélère tout tout s'accélère on a
besoin de faire toujours plus ave plus
deyz je vois danseil mais je aussi chez
mes clients aujourd'hui j'interviensun
grand groupe les gens il font des hires
de malade et ils vont encore avoir des
restriction budgétair qui font qui en
fait les personnes qui partent ne
sont et pour autant il faut pouir un
meilleur positionnement d'une entité au
sein d'une
boîte ENF moi j'attends le boom
VO j'attends mais je suis convaincu que
ça finira par
venir si cette jeune femme est
visiblement surchargée de travail
parfois la pression peut-être plus
insidieuse simplement d à l'usage
excessif de la communication numérique
les salariés sont merché par les mails
et ça ça augmente la charge mentale le
fait d'avoir des vous êtes en train de
travailler vous êtes en réunion c'est un
travail vous êtes en en train de
travailler sur un dossier vous êtes en
voilà et puis les mails continuent à
arriver les uns derrière les autres
derrière les autres alors parfois c'est
juste des mails pour tenir au courant le
fameux pi enfin pi c'est en français et
le fiy là pour ton information mais ils
sont noyés par les mail et puis parfois
il y a des informations qui passent à
l'AS parce que vous avez 60 mails et ils
vont louper celui qu'il fallait lire et
auquel il fallait réagir et et surtout
ce que je ressens c'est une priorité qui
chasse l'autre priorité une priorité
chasse l'autre priorité ça c'est une
réalité sentiment d'urgence excès
d'information débordement du travail
dans la sphère personnelle
l'hyperconnexion engendre des
risques c'est ce qui a voulu mesurer
Arthur Vinçon lui a créé un un
observatoire de ce qu'il appelle
l'infoobésité alors à chaque fois qu'il
se rend dans une entreprise bonjour tout
le monde il pose les mêmes questions
ouais très bien alors grosse journée
beaucoup de mails à traité ou pas ouais
actuellement un peu plus d'une
cinquantaine Arthur a recensé qu'un
cadreetaite entre 140 et 300 messages
par semaine et malgré le droit à la
déconnexion est dicté dans une loi de
2017 la journée de travail se prolonge
souvent à la
maison même avec le smartphone tu
arrivis pas à reconnecter ça dépend des
jours ouais il y a des jours oui et il y
a des jours non lorsqu'on a une période
avec beaucoup de projets et où on doit
être présent sur le terrain ou qu'on a
des événements par exemple en relation
école ben là le soir ben avec des
événements de rencontre avec des
candidats oui tu restes sur ton
téléphone pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
avoir une vision de ce qui se passe ou
carrment
oui dans cette grande entreprise d'audit
la DRH a conscience du problème bonjour
Mathilde ça va très bien mais les
chiffres de l'étude la surprennent quand
même on est bien je découvrais le le
petit fasicule avec les données ouais
ouais tu es content du résultat moi je
me ça me fait flipper pour moi
réfléchir car ce volume toujours plus
important d'email n'est pas sans
conséquence sur la santé cette densité
d'information et de sollicitation tout
le temps ça ça rend dingue en fait on
dit on est en train de devenir dingue
trop d'email trop de trop de réunions et
clairement nous on en mesure les le
stress numérique les les effets sur la
concentration sur le bien-être ça on le
mesure en plus on on fait beaucoup de
baromètres sociaux de performances
là-dessus donc on en parle librement on
sa le noir ouais sur l'hypercnexion on
se rendre compte que quand même il y a
quasiment un tiers des gens aujourd'hui
qui plus de 50 soires par an renvoient
des mails après leur journée de boulot
enfin c'est plus un c'est plus quelque
chose de négligeable en fait ça fait
partie du quotidien maintenant bah oui
je traite mes emails le soir parce que
moi j'ai du temps à la limite
flexibilité ok mais les destinataires
vont les recevoir oui mais c'est pas
grave je leur ai pas demandé de réponse
ouis alors ça c'est parce qu'on oublie
qu'il y a lien de subordination et moi
je reçois des emails de mon manager le
soir ou tôt le matin si c'est pas
explicité je m'attends à ce qu'il attend
une réponse ou en tous les cas pour
beaucoup ça va être faut que je sois
réactif faut répondre et cetera donc une
injonction implicite de faire quelque
chose et ça démultiplier bah en fait je
pense que nos cerveaux nos corps ne sont
enfin mais c'est déjà dans la tête ne
sont pas faits pour intégré et être
autant stimulé intellectuellement tout
le temps sur ce type de tâche c'est
exactement les conséquences de ce fil
qu'on a tiré pendant 40 ans pour urer sa
collègue analyser la façon dont les
mails sont gérer pourrait servir à
repérer un salarié en détresse par
exemple les gens qui ont une stratégie
zé mail le soir fin de journée il me
reste zéro mail à traiter dans ma boîte
mail en fait on peut voir que petit à
petit quand on va vers un burnout en
fait ça glisse quoi il va rester 10 10
mails puis 100 mail puis 200 mails et en
fait voilà on voit bien qu'au bout d'un
moment en fait quand c'est exact la
définition du stress que disait Arthur
c'est au bout d'un moment si on narrive
plus à le traiter bah là le stress
devient trop important et on finit par
craquer en fait bah ça nous on pense
qu'à un moment on va pouvoir
justement mesurer les signaux faibles de
ça en fonction des habitudes de travail
des personne quoi sans compter que la
crise sanitaire a accentué le
phénomène maintenant avec le travail à
distance l'hybride en fait on met plus
du tout de limite mais soi-même avec
enfin soi-même avec soi-même mais et
puis même en tant qu'organisation faut
rappeler quand même que bah là c'est la
pause déjeuner cétait un temps un peu
sacré où on mettait pas de réunion et en
fait petit à petit ça ça vu que chacun
s'est adapté pendant le covid il y avait
plus de temps pour caler tout ce qu'on
devait faire on a grignoté sur le temps
du déjeuner et dans les stat aujourd'hui
on voit bien que ce temps de déjeuner
n'est plus une pause autre changement
dans les entreprises les équipes
dirigeantes et les organisation sont de
plus en plus fréquemment renouvelés avec
leur bataillon de cadre intermédiaire
qu'il faut faire craquer coûte que coûte
pour qu'il quitte
l'entreprise c'est ce qui s'est passé
pour celle que nous appellerons
Suzanne après 20 ans de bons et loyaux
services et un poste de manager la
direction de son entreprise change
elle se voit très vite
convoquer j'ai été reçu par cette
présidence et euh elle a remis en cause
un point très précis de ma pratique
professionnelle pour laquelle je n'avais
jamais eu de difficultés jusqu'à présent
et j'avais même de la part de l'externe
une certaine reconnaissance de qualité
et il se trouve que cette présidence
avait tort sur le sujet même de cette
convocation et j'ai pu apporter dans
l'entretien une contradiction qui n'a
pas du tout plu et qui n'est pas passée
donc à partir de ce moment-là j'ai eu le
sentiment d'être la cible de quelque
chose que je ne cnait pas petit à petit
mon équipe était un en quelque sorte un
outil à la disposition de la gouvernance
pour m'atteindre pour me discréditer
pour me démotiver et le tout avec un
objectif de me faire quitter cette
entreprise par une démission sans doute
et le comportement d'une partie de mes
collaborateurs allit vraiment dans le
sens de
d'attaque malgré
tout
conv à nveau et lui propose une rupture
conventionnelle je mécroule toute seule
dans mon coin je ne le montre pas et je
demande à mettre fin à
entretien et de jours après je j'élabore
un scénario pour attenter à mes jour et
c'est mon excusez-moi c'est mon conjoint
qui décide che
médec
et et le médecin traitant me dit vous
êtes vous êtes victime de harcellement
moral depuis 2
ans je fais un retrait immédiat et vous
ne retournerez plus dans cette
entreprise parce que vous en courz un
risque vital
excusez-moi c'est encore très
douloureux Suzanne est en arrêt maladie
depuis 18 mois un arrêt qui peut se er 3
ans maximum ensuite le médecin du
travail la déclarera probablement inapte
à retourner dans cette entreprise et
elle sera
licenciée Muriel du mortier en fait le
constat tous les jours la souffrance
vécue au travail s'apparente à une
violence qui nécessite le plus souvent
un suivi
[Musique]
psychologique donc aujourd'hui je suis
revenue vous voir parce que ça fait un
moment que je vous avais pas vu
h
et donc je suis suivi j'ai j'ai été donc
suivie par une psychologue
oui je ne pense pas revenir dans mon
entreprise parce que c'est trop
douloureux il faut que vous retrouviez
la confiance aussi alors confiance en
vous parce que vous vous avez des
compétences même si on vous a dit que
vous ne saviez rien faire bah oui
évidemment vous savez faire bien
sûr ok ça marche ou
cette souffrance engendre une remise en
question qui va bien au-delà de la
sphère
professionnelle quand on est en
souffrance au travail enfin les salariés
qu' souffrance son travail ce sont pas
des des malades psychiatrique hein mais
c'est simplement ce sont des salariés
qui sont déstabilisés d'une façon
extrêmement profonde ça veut dire que
quand quand on a attaqué leur geste
professionnel en réalité on a mis euh à
mal leur identité profonde et c'est tout
ce chemin-là qu'il faut reparcourir avec
eux mais pourquoi certaines difficultés
professionnelles sont-elles capables de
déstabiliser à ce point un individu en
remettant en cause son identité profonde
une des raisons serait que les
techniques de développement personnel et
leur injonction à s'accomplir dans
toutes les sphères de la vie n'ont pas
échappé au milieu de l'entreprise c'est
la thèse de Thierry Jobar selon lui
souscouvert d'aider les individus à se
se sentir mieux avec des prêtes à penser
du
genre renouer avec sa bonté profonde le
bonheur d'être soi et celui-là que j'ai
trouvé ce matin je dote mon narcissisme
toutes les clés pour enfin
s'aimer les méthodes de développement
personnel aurait en fait un effet
pervers en milieu professionnel celui de
faire reposer sur le seul salarié les
dysfonctionnements de l'entreprise les
salariés on va leur demander d'être
créatif de s'impliquer
de vouloir se réaliser dans son travail
de vouloir s'accomplir dans son travail
cet engagement corps et â du
salarié c'est plus simplement son
travail qui compte c'est sa personne et
si son travail est remis en question sa
personne l'
aussi à partir de ce momentl jamais il
vont mettre en question l'organisation
ou le process ou les procédures ou la
[Musique]
hiérarchieantvag aussi aider beaucoup
évoquent ici un bestcellerire du genre
les quatre accords toltech qui édictent
quatre grands principes de
vie il y en a un dont je me sers
vraiment régulièrement c'est quand
quelqu'un me fait quelque chose qui me
plaisse je me dis ne le prends pas pour
moi il y a quelque chose qu'on fait dans
un des quatre accords ne le prends pas
pour toi-même c'est son sa situation à
lui qui fait qu'il te renvoie cette
parole donc ça ça m'aide beaucoup
oui I mais si vous voulez il y a un
autre un des autres enseignements des
accordoltech alors je sais plus
exactement la formulation qui est quand
même brillantissime et je voudrais la
dénaturer c'est alors
attends que votre parole soit
impeccable voilà en entreprise que votre
parole soit impeccable donc ça veut dire
quoi ça ça veut dire que si vous avez un
problème par exemple parce que le cas a
été documenté si vous êtes victime de
harcèlement pendant des mois moi et que
ça vous détruit et que vous voulez en
parler à votre
hiérarchie va vous dire attends que ta
parole soit impeccable tu peux pas dire
ça comme ça tu es trop agressif tu
laisses parler ton émotion il faut le
dire de telle ou telle façonoui et
qu'est-ce qui se passe et ben on est
désapproprié de son propre langage pour
utiliser le langage de la NVE langue
nolbérale comme ça on francera personne
ça ne changera rien et la souffrance de
la personne harcelé elle sera toujours
là c'est ça le
problème la crise sanitaire a été un
facteur aggravant de la souffrance au
travail selon santé publque France la
dépression serait désormais à l'origine
de 40 % des arrêts de
[Musique]
travail